we need to share our understanding and
our experience but also to build an
understanding of the European model of
diversity management which includes
charters
what finally brought us to the point to
sign the Carter is to to all our
engagement in the work of the Charter as
itself and to hopefully share
experiences and best practices with our
other companies diversity and inclusion
is a key issue today and in future and
it has now been incorporated into the
corporate thinking of employees and also
of the corporate culture
HIV positive column management oseary a
la pecan park west important additional
radiosity patootie totalbiscuit republic
good evening to work with diversity
means that you really get aware of the
fact that people are different and also
they have different competencies that
can be used in the company in a very
good way both for the company and for
the individual you cannot exclude women
or disabled or or my dance ends of all
sorts it's really question of
productivity and developed of society as
a whole diversity of course creates
conflict because it is proven from a
scientific point of view but if it is
managed and leveraged is the promoter
the greatest promoter of innovation and
efficiency
we do a lot of promotion with we are
always trying to work on awareness so we
organized a lot of events we are very
present in the media also and with
always constricting strong partnership
this is the main point of our approach
in Brussels we have specific diversity
consultants to support companies so our
approach is to to support them during
two years or more in their diversity
action plan we really appreciate that
the European Commission has provides
this European charters platform because
it's really important to share the
knowledge within the countries and
across the countries I think in AU
platform is very important for all our
companies who are engaged or doing
business in other European countries so
I hope of a better exchange and
hopefully signing or different routers
in different countries
you